the aftermath of yet another russian
missile strike in kharkiv
this mainly russian-speaking city
ukraine's second largest has suffered
some of the worst shelling since
russia's invasion more than seven weeks
ago
emergency services say at least one
person was killed and many more injured
in this attack that caused the fire to
spread into residential areas
around 11 o'clock today the emergency
services received a message that an
enemy missile had hit a five-story
administrative building a rescue team in
tanker trucks was dispatched to the
scene
in the town of trotsyarnet in the sunmi
region northwest of kharkiv
families gathered to mourn some of the
latest victims
the un says that more than 1900
civilians have been killed including at
least 162 children since the war started
russian forces laid mines in the
cemetery before withdrawing from the
area a couple of weeks ago
a father cries over his dead son's grave
civilians and soldiers are buried here
we held a funeral for my son when they
liberated trotsky next
we were afraid thinking maybe some of
the russian fascists are still here and
they'll blow up the grave
we put a photo of him there how he
always was always smiling always
cheerful always positive
hundreds of kilometers away in the
western city of levive where local
authorities say four russian missiles
were intercepted on saturday morning
volunteers prepared humanitarian aid
please do not
stop helping us do not stop providing us
with humanitarian assistance because
more and more people are
fleeing
their homes and they need your help
please don't stop helping us
after a second attack in two days on a
ukrainian weapons facility in the
capital kiev the ukrainian military
warned of potentially more to come
due to the presence of russian warships
armed with sea launched cruise missiles
in the black sea there is an increased
threat of the occupiers using missile
arms against the defense industrial
facilities and logistics infrastructure
of our state
bodies lie on the streets in the
besieged port city of mariopol where
russian forces again said they had taken
full control of a steel plant
the ukrainian army denies that saying
marines and members of the azov
battalion are still defending their
positions
in the giant soviet-built factory
in a city almost completely destroyed
and from where thousands of civilians
have been unable to escape
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky is warning russia not to in his
words eliminate the last remaining
ukrainian soldiers inside the besieged
city of mariopol or it will be the end
of peace talks
peace talks that the russian president
vladimir putin recently described as
having reached a dead end
chance trafford al jazeera kiev